[Music]  how many of you are there  not enough people abducted from or near  STAR Labs here's the potential purple  parademons  okay the demons must have caught the  scent of the lava box they carried  people away to find out what they know  so they may still be alive  nine oh the head of STAR Labs was taken  as well you made it so then there must  be a nest nearby I plotted all the  sightings of Metropolis Gotham no  pattern I can see the lines on the map  don't converge on land Beasley back to  Braxton Island between the two cities  Gotham Harbor these are air vents they  all need down to the town to Metropolis  project that was abandoned to this  Friday night  [Music]  do you really think that oh wow they  just they really just vanish huh oh  that's rude  you